how did you find working with capella I
actually enjoyed it because if I smile
on your face
so um they had Ronaldo Ronaldinho we
found a from Platinum generation three
three ballon doors yeah yeah and then
they had caca on the boat do you think
this England team can actually do it 100
they can do it they've got phenomenal
players I think this is probably the
best atmosphere I've ever seen within an
England squad we do have the Firepower
we do have the team
[Music]
hello and welcome to sport Bible stories
sponsored by Budweiser the official beer
of England I'm Rory Jennings and I'm
Josh Denzel and today we have an icon on
sport Bible stories I am delighted to
welcome the one and only Emil heske into
the studio
thank you so much thank you for coming
on it's great to have you here obviously
there's a World Cup looming and you have
represented England at two major
tournaments yes uh two major World Cups
yes
um 2002 and 2010. so yeah that must have
been amazing that that actually means
that you qualify as part of the golden
generation yes sadly
no I think yeah it was great to go to
them tournaments um I think obviously
getting far in the uh getting to the
quarters in the 2002 was amazing
golden generation and the thing is we
talk about gold generation and we went
out on the cause to Brazil so um they
had Ronaldo Ronaldinho Rivaldo from
Platinum generation three three three
ballon doors yeah yeah and then they had
caca on the bench yeah
it's amazing but it says something about
like the mentality of England fans
before that's a disgrace that we lost to
them yeah I know
yeah that is true so Emma we are
delighted to have you here uh to warm
you up we're going to dive straight into
some quick fire questions if that's all
right may I ask you who was your
favorite player growing up
uh John Barnes okay uh which club did
you support growing up Liverpool
favorite player now
still messy
who's the favorite manager you played
under
two Martin O'Neill and Gerald Julia
what about favorite manager that you
didn't play for
is there anyone you would love to have
played for
probably jugging now
yeah Jurgen klop take that what's your
proudest moment in football that's tough
um I don't if if I was to take one I'd
probably just say making my debut but I
had so many moments
who's been the most influential person
on your career
send parents
nice what's your biggest interest
outside of football
probably
what's one thing you couldn't live
without
probably not a phone yeah yeah I'll move
you there Tick Tock
that's a problem and if you could give
our listeners one piece of advice what
would be the best piece of advice that
you've ever heard
football advice
um win your individual battle and help
you make
generous football yeah I love that
um so we're going to start now and we're
going to talk about your early career
that's all right
um you know when you were coming through
when you were developing as a footballer
was it clear to those around you and
even maybe to yourself that you were
destined for the top right were you
clearly the best footballer in your
school clearly the best yes but um I
think
I actually preferred Athletics so I
actually yeah I preferred athletic I
preferred sprinting and and long jump
um so but then obviously you it's very
organized isn't it but then when you're
playing football you can just jump over
a gate and go and play yeah and just go
and mess about so that became my go-to
and uh yeah I was always playing with
bigger bigger kids even though small I
only really started growing when I was
15 16. but you were you were a tiddler
really yeah small small not small but
yeah but yeah compared to what I I grew
up into yeah I was small
yeah and then like uh playing by the
time I was 15 16 I was playing with the
18s right so then you kind of know that
I'm going somewhere so initially with
the interest being Athletics did you
potentially see a career in that route
or did you always want to be a football
field yeah but then you had link for
Christie's yeah yeah you come up a good
time with footballers
so they would they would that was the
generation you're watching that and he's
winning gold medals he's winning races
and you just want to beat them and that
was it that's incredible now I was at 87
you signed for
Leicester
he has a nine year old did you so like
when you look at it like that obviously
you knew that you were going to be a
player because you've got professional
clubs looking at you but how did that
start how did that conversation happen
were you kicking it about on school
school days yeah so um I actually didn't
play Sunday League football
until after I joined Leicester
yeah you do it the other way around here
so basically I joined Leicester as a
nine-year-old and obviously in a in a
Christian black household Sundays for
worshiping it's for church so I would do
that and then obviously training with I
was spotted at school
um playing a game and then I was asked
to come as a trial got through that and
then a parent who's doing Sunday League
football asked me to come down but it
was clean on the other side of Leicester
so I was living on one side it was on
the other side my mum and dad weren't
driving at the time so we were catching
buses and they were coming over picking
me up and taking me back
so that's how I got into Sunday League
football
so you were playing Leicester before
Sunday League that's that's a very rare
Journey yeah I did it the other way
around did they know
yeah you're allowed to do that well at
the time you were allowed to play Sunday
League football until you were 15 I
think okay
um so it was it was called Center of
Excellence right it was totally
different and then when did you progress
through to representing England at what
age group uh 16
yeah okay so it was a very quick Journey
the trajectory is sort of slower
at the time it was Lily Shaw so my age
group Jamie carragher
um Andy ducrow Frank Lampard
um Rio was a young but Rio played up
um
uh well Jodie Morris has been in that
two years younger a bit younger right
yeah
um who else
is in Christy yeah so that was a good
side how did you do when you were
competing I think we're doing okay and
we got to I think this uh went under 16s
got to
uh quarters I think it was
um but I actually didn't join the the
academy that that uh Lily Shaw uh mum
and dad didn't want me to leave because
he had to go and go to school there you
have to stay there and they just didn't
really leave so I didn't go on a trial
or anything and then I at 16 playing
obviously playing up playing into in the
eight under 18s I went for a trial like
a trial day with the national team and
then next minute I'm playing in the
Euros
everything seems to happen yeah
yeah so I went from 50 under 15s playing
under 18s
and then 16's playing regularly under
18s
and then well yeah my career went a bit
crazy actually then so 16 hours left
school joined Academy what shoes yts 16
playing with the first team
got injured come back with the the 18th
played a few games with the 80s and went
back with the first team member debut at
17. Davis Leicester at 17. how was that
mad who was it against uh QPR we lost
two nil I was I was traveling by then I
was traveling with the first team yeah
um
so I was one that would help out every
now and again join in some of this but I
was traveling with them just to feel
what it was like
that night but it was a night game that
night uh that day a lot of the lads went
down six so I was the well it's the only
other forward to be played so I was uh
that's when I made my debut was it
Filbert Street nice yeah what do you
remember about the day was it like it
must have been yeah yeah it was a bit
crazy but he they did it well for me
because they never told me so you didn't
have time to get nervous basically what
they used to do was
um and I think there's some some
managers probably still do it now you go
into the changes two hours before the
game and they reveal who's who's
actually playing and that was what I'll
find out that's incredible and what
about your first goal
good question uh we played it was
against Norwich uh across I think it was
Simon Grayson cross nipped into the near
post and and uh got it in did you plan
the celebration at that point
I'm I'm ready now I've got something
I've got something lined up I've got the
roly-poly I haven't planned anything
although you have got one of the most
iconic celebrations in World football
yeah yeah
how quickly how quickly did you jump on
uh on the change room DJ I was never
changing and the thing is like even back
then so you really didn't have changed
your room actually never know Bluetooth
but now it it was
um by that time it was we were we were
probably all getting our own yeah yeah
yeah you do your own thing and you know
by that point you're scoring goals
regularly are you dreaming of playing
for England is England the ultimate
ambition if I'm honest with you once I
got to 16s it was like Wow singing a
national anthem and you you got that
pride and you think this is it
you don't you don't know if you're going
to go any further so you're taking that
all yeah then you get to the 18s and
you're like wow same again and you get
20 ones and it's like I'm now one step
but that helped me in my in my
progression up to the first thing
because I kind of knew it from 16's what
totally totally different there's like a
road map and the football is totally
different as well yeah it's not as
aggressive as the Premier League
it's more tactical uh Defenders are more
uh some Defenders aggressive but some
like understand what you want to do and
they're trying to it's like a chess game
speaking to the boys when I'm in Camp
now every time I would chat to them
after training especially the boys
who've just who've just come out and say
like how was it and the overriding
feeling they get before they go is like
I cannot wait to play with these players
and like they get there in this it's
always the first thing they always say
is the intensity is a different level
another level why is that I went to the
16 so I obviously come from less than
playing with the under 18s playing uh
from from 15 so you're you're thinking
like yeah I'm I'm ready yeah you go to
the 60s no
so how we had Nigel Causey
yeah and he was phenomenal so he would
ping a ball with his right foot and I'm
like okay he's right footed then he ping
above his left one like is he left
footed and then you'd have to try and do
the saying it same thing as well uh and
you but you learn and you have to you
have to learn very quickly because it's
intensity and the technical ability that
they want from you is a high level so
when did you feel like you were
established that's a difficult one to be
honest with you because you never really
feel like you're established because
when you when you're in the mix I guess
do you as a player know that there's a
buzz around me now like yeah people are
watching me yeah again
um once I came into the Premier League
with Leicester
and then started making England
appearances and then you'll see uh teams
coming to watch you that's when you know
yeah there's a silverware with Leicester
must have been a massive moment yeah
huge huge um
the thing is you know when you come up
to the Premier League and everyone say
now you're getting relegated blah blah
so you want to prove everyone wrong so
that first season we've got to um we won
The League Cup
um then two says later we get to the
league final
lose that dispers and then the season
after we win it again
and we finished up after the table and
for a team that's talking about it
should be relegated every season you're
like yeah we're doing all right here and
we just had a we had a bunch of players
that were knew what wanted to be
together wanted to fight for each other
and knew what we were all about and we
had a manager that made you think about
running through a bit more it was
fantastic at that and get get you on his
side so you know when you're discuss in
there like the love and affection that
you have for the manager Leicester city
and the fans
the move to Liverpool is it was it just
too good an opportunity to turn down uh
by that time like I just said I'd gone
to three Cup finals in four years
um it's outrageous achievement right so
yeah isn't it that's incredible yeah and
we'd finished uh top off of the table
um and then the next step was what do
what do where's the club going what am I
what do I want to do I was in England
regular by then
training and playing with all these
players uh The Next Step was to see if I
could do it higher up and Liverpool came
in Spurs Villa
I think leads as well I had a rumor
Martin O'Neil I think there's a quote I
don't know whether this is this is a
real quote or not but he says I think
there was a time when you were getting
touted to go to to Liverpool I think the
fee was was going to be around 7 million
quid and uh Martin O'Neill said that
we'll get double from Barcelona if and
if that happens I'll drive him there
myself yeah yeah he probably did say
that that was what he was like honestly
um got in a little bit of trouble as
well because I think my agent at the
time uh uh had probably told him that I
was going to sign a new contract
so yeah
but then he left straight after so I I
about to say he was probably doing the
same thing as you yeah yeah yeah he's
all guys we're rolling that belt so how
come you chose Liverpool yeah being
being a Liverpool fan no I was with my
uncle all the time and he was a
Liverpool fan so so and John Barnes was
one of my favorite players so yeah
always wanted to play for them and then
when they came in it was like that's
where I want to go as a player you look
at the dress room and go like I cannot
wait to link up with you I think I'll
play well with you or just I want to
test myself every day against his bed
who were those players in that Liverpool
dressing room you had uh Jamie riding up
you had Robbie you had Michael
um
schmitzer Paddy Burger
um it's a good Liverpool Stefan hencho
and this is a fun thing so we I joined
them right and the first training
session
um at Leicester we really didn't tackle
because you know we've got a huge Squad
and you want to keep everyone you know
you're starting 11 you want to keep
everyone fit so we're going but we
wouldn't really tackle uh 50 50 you'd go
in but you're not going full out
first training session get the ball
Pinch A Bank slightly Straight From Here
welcome to newborn as well okay cool
cool I understand this now but now it
was good fun because he played the thing
is the fascinating thing with football
you've really got to try and train the
way you you're going to play because
that's a rehearsal for what you want to
do in that Liverpool team who were the
big characters in the dressing room was
he yeah Jamie even then as well them two
together like uh nuts really yeah but
he's disgusting
they feel at home you know I mean even
nine in if you look at him on Sky it's
the same thing you want to be the
loudest in the room he's always got he's
always got something to say yeah and you
obviously formed that partnership with
Michael Owen and that was replicated at
Club level and at International level
it was potentially the best form that
Michael Owen ever had linking up with
you I think it goes back to National
Team actually national team under 18 so
Michael's two years younger than me so
he would have been 16 and came to our
18s
um and that's where it just kind of
clicked from there fascinating thing is
we played France Henry chose a gay
uh William Gala Silvestre Willy Samuel
Usman Dabo this is
yeah yeah but that Region 2 we talk
about gun generation that was just my
age group yeah yeah and then you add in
zizu you add in to amyadin uh
at that point it was like wow this like
everyone if you look at the Brazil side
you look at the France side it's an
iconic area of football I don't know
maybe that's just a show in our age now
we're like we're like that that's when I
when I was coming into football this is
unreal these guys are giants these guys
they're still they're still regarded as
a Giants so we're talking about that's
just my age group and we played them and
the manager was Julio and I was playing
up front with Michael we I think there's
one one we drew with them and it was
funny because then he'll bring he brings
me to Liverpool to team up with Michael
but I'd play with the national team from
then onwards with Michael so we just
formed a partnership and it was it just
fit well yeah what was it about playing
with him that you you enjoyed so much or
what was the reason why that that
partner I just think we got each other
so if I know where
automatically he knows what I want to do
automatically I know what he wants to do
and where he's going to run so if I get
the ball and I turn I know he's going to
make a run for me and he's and he and
and I know exactly where he wants the
ball and he knows exactly what I want to
do so it just makes it easier you know
if you're flicking a ball on it
yeah no one's running you lay a ball off
no one's there yeah no I let him off I
know Michael's there I flick a ball and
Michael knows that he's got to get
behind yeah I'm going up for a header
Michael knows that he's got to come in
front of me to just knock it down and
then he might leave me back in whatever
it may be we already know what we each
other did you purposefully and sort of
opt into choosing the role as the foil
for Michael did you did you try to
adopt a position that would accentuate
his positive and potentially probably
but again it worked in my favor as well
because that was what I was good at yeah
and that was my all that was my game and
I could adapt my game to whatever you
know
um
if you look at the early part of my
career it was adapted because we had to
make runs in in behind so I was quick
make runs in behind create chances
across the ball
and then as a typical number nine I need
to hold up the ball but I can duck that
game
um because I'm able to do that and my
game was very adaptable I played left
wing play right wing I could do them no
problem hit them all and Michael Owen
are you still mates yeah we still speak
to each other but more so when we're
doing work together right yeah right
right because obviously Joe did you ever
in in when you talk about playing that
incredible frosting in that age group
you and Julia ever speak previous to
because I know it was it was a long time
where he's going to Liverpool everyone
kind of knew it but it was like the
unwritten thing so did you did he ever
speak to you and go listen I like the
way you play I've got this idea I think
we can be successful it wasn't until
just before I was I'd gone there so
before that no I hadn't spoken to anyone
what was he like as a magic very
different yeah very different I mean I
mean you listen it's like talking cheese
yeah but it's tactical awareness as well
so I'd gone from
um a manager Justice personally wanting
the best from you blah blah and giving
you the right to be the best you
possibly can but really tactically we
didn't really work on loads of stuff it
was you're good at this go and do it
yeah you're good at taking place I'm
gonna do it if you get if you lose it
don't worry get it back and go and do it
again because you're like oh I've got it
right here the best I possibly can but
then obviously going to Liverpool where
it's more tactical you've got a lot of
the ball so you've got no runs to be
made what the opposition are doing but I
remember sitting in we never did
meetings well hardly ever did meetings
at Leicester but then every day we do
meetings at Liverpool in like 45 minutes
so imagine sitting in the room you got
you got the the TV there pitch black
room I'm at the back sleeping
yeah yeah you you're there like
what was going on what what was
happening basically it's tactics he's
talking about the opposition he's
talking about what the runs they're
going to be making and everything on the
presentation yeah so
um in the end obviously you get used to
sitting there and it's it's important
it's it but it's it's everyday thing now
but back then it was brand new yeah it
was obviously it's alien coming from
I've been successful here yeah I'm a
strategy to score goals I I know how it
works I played with him before there you
go so then obviously but it's fantastic
so the detail that they would go into
was brilliant and that was what you got
that's why you get the best at yourself
at times and then we'd walk through
tactics on the pitch for like 40 minutes
really just walking through it so yeah
he was he was phenomenal did you ever
get like a sense of you know when you
play for your Boyhood club like I can't
I can't even imagine it but that was
there an Extended pressure is there an
extra layer of oh I'm walking out I've
dreamed of this as a kid in my bedroom
and now now I'm living and breathing it
no you know the fascinating thing is you
don't you you it's other people that put
pressure on you yeah you never put
pressure on yourself until other people
put the pressure on you and then you
start overthinking things because it's
what you know and it's what you know
you're good at so you just go out there
and do it and then once people start
saying no you didn't do this well you
never even thought yeah yeah yeah you're
like oh didn't I yeah really it's got
that got the TV why do you make that
right yeah I'm telling everyone man that
sort of pressure that's when the
pressure comes but I I never overthink
things you you just gotta undo
Emmy probably the craziest night of your
career the the UEFA Cup Final against
alaves 5'4 what was it like to feature
in that game amazing obviously playing
in the finals fantastic
um never thought that I'd play in a
UEFA got final but uh finally got there
and just a great do you know do you know
the fascinating thing with that final
right so if you look at it we'd probably
played
60 I think that might have been the 61st
game or something like that and then we
have one more game I think we have one
more League game which you had to win to
get into the Champions League so
um
by that time adrenaline I was running on
adrenaline because it's been a long
season and I wasn't used to that when
you when when I think about it yes we
had a lot of games with Leicester in the
sense of going to one cup final but then
when you go into three and some of them
are like uh home run away
it's a lot of games it's about that time
I was just running on my adrenaline then
I watched the game back to know what it
was like as in what happened
um yeah I mean it but you kind of just
but then to score that final goal Macker
it's got that final gone we didn't even
know what to do to be honest yeah wasn't
it so everyone's like oh yeah yeah it
was like oh we've won it yeah what was
the atmosphere like in the stadium
amazing amazing such a fantastic stadium
and you had a big stand there's just so
many fans
nice and same year painful memory for me
honestly I I tell you a story about it
like you came back
it's a really if I got fun with that
Michael 11 final one I cried into my
pillow for about four nights after that
it scarred it scarred me for life
how was it the FA Cup finals Cardiff
right incredible experience sure
definitely cooked final you know you
know growing up you obviously there's
there's one cup that you really want to
win and that's the FA Cup because For Me
growing up that's the one that you can
see on television that's on free to Air
kind of thing so uh yeah phenomenal
um opportunity to go on with it playing
against a very very good Arsenal side we
were flying at that point as well
creating chances as well you had plenty
of
chances
um VAR was it yeah
but yeah Michael and the fascinating
thing is any game with Michael in it you
know you've got a chance to win yeah
because you know anything dropping in
the Box Michael got a chance of getting
onto it and then it was the the goal
where he scores when I think it's Paddy
Burger plays him over the back
that goes brilliant because I can see
what they're trying to do he's trying to
show him on his left foot but he takes
it yeah and then slots it in yeah
phenomenal It's actually an example that
goal to demonstrate quite how Elite my
clothes was there wasn't it because not
only is he won Liverpool the FA Cup
which is a huge statement in itself but
he's done what he's done to that
brilliant Arsenal team and then I
individually it's Tony Adams yeah yeah
like one of the best defenders that you
could possibly do to take it on his weak
foot like that was amazing yeah and
that's Michael that's Michael for you
you know when you look at Michael Owen
and what he's actually achieving what
he's done
don't think he really people realize how
good he was and I don't think people
realize that it probably hasn't been
done since I think he's marred by
the the the not reaching that level of
form later on in his career but people
don't really you don't remember that do
you know what I think he's really
unlucky do you think there's anything in
this emu I feel like he's a little bit
unlucky Owen for for the Legacy like I
always back up you know when people have
these conversations about in their Prime
what I always say Owen but I think
because he was a Liverpool because he
was from Liverpool came through then
went to win the league at Manchester
United I feel like he's kind of
alienated both that could possibly it
but you can't take away from what he's
actually done
yeah this is the last English player to
win in Ballon d'Or isn't it
do you think that Liverpool team you
know when we talk about these players
and we can wax lyrical about them for so
long such a good team brilliant manager
should you have won the league possibly
again I think it's more consistency
um for us we've gone
beat Arsenal uh uh then lose Charlton or
John
yeah yeah
um and that consistency you know that
the the the the the the Invincible year
the consistency was phenomenal you're
not going you you might be down one nil
but you know you're going to come back
and something's gonna happen and we we
never had that consistency and the thing
is we're very young so when I look at
myself I was 22 and I went to Liverpool
um Michael's two years younger than me
Stevie's three years younger than me uh
so Kyle is my age so we had a fairly
young sign and we brought um Gary McAn
he was fantastic for us to be honest
with a bit having a senior figure in
there uh Gary McAllister was brilliant
but he just couldn't get that that
little bit out of ourselves where we're
going from there's too much swing we
never had the consistency right so the
form was going well for Liverpool the
partnership with Owen was brilliant the
natural trajectory is England and how
was that when you first got your call up
and you were training with this England
team it was a great side wasn't it yeah
the thing was um it was it was great to
be called up into the squad just the
train um at that time I think Glenn
hoddle was doing stuff like that he was
brilliant because he would bring in Rio
just to train with him just to be in and
around the environment and get them used
to the universe when they do eventually
break into the team on a full-time basis
Rio had it and a few others had it and
then eventually I got my turn and it was
brilliant to be around it and you kind
of ignore because you've got Ian right
looking at him right doing finishing and
I know sure we're doing finishing like
yeah no it was phenomenal to be around
them players it must have been
incredible to see players like that
playing like he was in them it was an
outrageous
yeah so just being around that was and
that's what I say with um you know when
when
um the manager brings players in
and
the reason sometimes he's bringing
players in to see what they're like in
the environment yeah because it's
totally different it's key it's totally
different to the club environment yeah
what was your proudest moment playing
for England probably five one yeah
probably the five one but making a debut
as well I was lucky enough to have my
grandparents see me play for the
national team as well so that's great is
that something that
it's such a big thing you know you talk
about playing an FA Cup finals you talk
about making debut here Club there's
something special about yeah playing for
England there's something standing on
the touchline you see a number come up
and it's like I'm gonna get my phone I
can't take that away from you as well
yeah
but you can't take it away from you
which is fantastic um and that other
achievements that's one of the biggest
ones do you still feel that Josh
obviously you're around the England team
at the moment you know when players are
gonna play for England do they do you
feel like this squad have that kind of
sense of majesty about the occasion and
that oh for sure like I'm lucky enough
to kind of Welcome uh new players into
the into the camp and I sit down and
talk to them and it's like
there's a buzz and there's there's an
excitement of just being around honestly
it's like they're looking around saying
George Park and they've been there
probably through old age groups right
but it it looks different I think
there's a glitter on it when when they
when they come to the first income and
they're doing media duties for them and
they're kind of looking around and going
wow can't wait and usually I get them
just after the first training session
and they're why I died they're like oh
my God you should have seen Harry Kane
and trying to shoot I didn't realize
Bellingham had it like that and it's
like they're like kids it's like if I
went to Australia it's the same
conversation you have and then they just
hope they get fit they hope they'll get
minutes sounds it's like you realize I
think we're now starting to learn your
generation they didn't treat football as
like people almost like you're just
footballers right I think now people are
starting to understand because they can
see hang on like this is exactly how I
would react if I was there like exactly
to be an incredible football to me yeah
yeah
I mean he's playing for the national
team but there's there is a massive
sense of majesty and and you can tell it
means so much that the players even
talking to the boys previous to this
we're like we've got World Cup 55-man
scored like are we going I hope I see it
you know what I mean they're desperate
to go what do you reckon's the best
thing playing for England then overall
and is there like one being at Wembley
and playing in front of the home crowd
to be honest with you um I was lucky
enough to play in both
so I blame the old one I played a new
one so I was lucky enough to play in
both and just being there singing a
national anthem in front of your home
funds and seeing your family in the
crowd yeah nothing better and what's
your memories of the five one in Munich
good memories again these sven's first
competitive game I believe and um
Sam was brilliant in the sense of
tactically uh he was very calm with his
tactics as well so he'd tell you he'd
have this little border and he'd been
moving these little
think these little mannequin things that
you just move around so telling you
where to go and he was brilliant at that
and then going out onto the pitch we
went one nil down after some like seven
minutes and
yeah but the thing was we had good
players so as long as we could settle
things down we'll find and whilst we did
and we scored at Key moments so the the
second goal went in at uh just before
half time so you've gone from being one
and look
in seven minutes probably should have
been two nil up it's even makes a
fantastic save to then going in half
time two one down deflated
and then you come back out and we score
again 3-1 you're like they're gone yeah
yeah can you see that on the picture
because usually in Germany you know
they're quite pragmatic like you know
they never they've never done that
because you see in the eyes of the
players and you can see it but when you
when you're playing that game did you
stick out you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna really stick it on you yeah free
while go for the jugular was that like
we always think that anyway
um but it would you know sometimes
everything just happens and it just you
know the chances are coming I nodded it
down for Michael he finishes he gets
played through scols he plays me through
anything and I finish and it's five one
it's just like wow what just happened
the worst thing is you can't really
celebrate because you've got another
game on Tuesday yeah yeah I was going to
ask you were there any celebrations
we've got another game so you basically
yeah well done jump on the plane back go
and play again was that straight into
that wasn't straight into Greece was it
uh yeah I think I was here well I was
agreed yeah when Beckham scores to get
us right up in that one yeah that was an
Old Trafford that wasn't it I just
remember to celebrate and I've got a
great great uh picture of my celebration
with big so I mean at that moment we
were in danger of not going into a major
tournament so it's like at that point do
you believe or you sat there with
everything across I stood there of
everything crossed thinking
I don't know I'm gonna yeah and then the
media is gonna the media is gonna kill
us you know what I look back now and I I
never thought we wasn't going to make it
honestly
um and you're playing Greece yeah yeah
of course yeah you're playing Greece and
yeah okay come down to that last free
kick but yeah I never thought that we
wasn't going to make it honestly and in
bang you're on a plane to Korea Japan
yeah that must have felt amazing great
you were going yeah and a great and a
great tournament as well
um first of all you get you get
obviously the long list and then
suddenly you play a couple of games and
then they Whittle it down and then being
on the yeah being on that plane was
phenomenal how'd you get the call up
just get a text message or someone calls
you oh it's literally a caller yeah so I
got I thought it'd be like way more
Grand than that when they say the call
up they mean the cool it might be
different now but no no it's exactly the
same yeah okay just go go over
congratulations or someone will call you
Gareth maybe if you go oh by the way
like so I'll give you a funny one I'll
give you one uh we so I've been out of
the squad for a long time and come back
in and do Steve McLaren so I was driving
home and someone I think it was uh Anton
I was at Wigan at the time and he was
driving home with me
um and someone calls me like and I
usually don't I'm thinking what's this
answered it all right emailed it Steve
all right Steve
McLaren
[Laughter]
all right Steve because you know at that
time the players would do stupid things
and call you up potentially without you
on your guard yeah so I'm like all right
Steve
um yeah I've been talking to Michael
blah blah I want to want you to come
back into the squad and it was only then
that it clicked when he said talking to
Michael and stuff like oh this is Steve
yeah I bet that's the real reaction
you start putting your phone voice on
so so that was when I got back into the
squad was it was it a surprise because
no I was playing well yeah I was playing
well at the time and uh yeah I was at
Wigan
um but I was playing well
and uh I think there was a couple of
injuries
um so yeah I I know I knew I was going
to get back into the squad at some stage
um because I I had faith in my own
ability and I knew what the that was
needed
um so yeah and then I got called back in
time nice and you know when you went
over to Korea in Japan how was that
tournament like who who are you close to
in that Squad
um probably jmo at the time there's a
few funny stories about Jamie James yeah
yeah it was a bit crazy
um and we talk about so you're going to
tournaments and you talk about so much
time you have and
um I thought Sven dealt with that quite
well so we'd um we'd have time up with
the with the players so we'd go to the
mall together and just even just walk
around together and that yeah it was
great so we'd have uh six six security
guards with us four for Becks
for the rest of us so during that
tournament the hype in England was very
much this team can win it it was golden
generation talk you know we had venko
and Erickson it was
exciting did you believe that that Squad
could win it were you going to that
World Cup to win it 100 yeah we below we
believe that we could win it um
and when we got to Brazil went one
little was yeah so
um yeah and we just wasn't ready to come
home we were ready to go all the way and
that was just devastating but again you
look at Generations as well they went on
to win it yeah with three ballon d'ors
up front and uh one or someone sat on
the bench can I ask a question about
that that game do you think Ronaldinho
meant that I don't think it's so in the
game where were you when that happened
uh so it come from here and swung into
there I was in them right in the middle
okay you had a perfect view this is an
eyewitness you don't think he meant it
when I when I watched it back I'm like I
think he actually meant that but I don't
think he meant it in that corner I think
he meant it in the other one it was a
shot now you think yeah 100 cool you
missed out in 2006.
how does that that make you feel because
it's when you've been involved in a
tournament and you almost half expect to
go you know and you know what you're
missing I guess
I didn't actually I didn't half expect
to go because again the 2004 wasn't a
great tournament so um you kind of know
and then I hadn't been called up into a
couple of squads so I thought yeah
that's fine but it was great to sit back
and watch it as a spectator as well
um and watch games that way
but uh but they're phenomenal like I
said they're phenomenal tournaments you
always want to go to all of them and
yeah I felt I missed out on one there
but they they you know you you I managed
to sneak myself back in yeah and you're
obviously going to be watching this
World Cup coming up what do you think do
you think this England team can actually
do it they 100 they can do it they've
got a phenomenal uh some great players
um young players as well
um as long as you don't put too much
pressure on them you know yeah yeah
the thing is you always you're always
going to put pressure on people again
when there was no pressure on them um
for the for the was it the world cup or
the Euros I think it was yours
but then they went to they went to the
semi-final of the final now not his
expectation that they must win it yeah
right
um
and they've got to have that feeling
that they've got though but I think as
as fans we've just got to keep give them
the right energy as players I think if
you go into a tournament thinking we
can't win it it should have been yeah
you spoke about every time you went that
you were in a squad or you went to a
tournament you think yeah
I think this squad really got to be
proved yeah that we get to a semi-fund
we get to a final we do have the
Firepower we do have the team to go and
we and you know what I think this squad
has maybe more so than any squad I can
think of
depth I think you could argue
potentially that maybe your side 06
could be compared in terms of the first
11 but the depth of that team wasn't
particularly striking whereas the depth
of this squad is amazing isn't it like
we have we have excellent players in
virtually every position two two or
three in every every position which is
great and that pushes everyone as well
to be honest with you again because I
know if I'm having a bad game yeah yeah
yeah
um you know but you've got the captain
hurricane who probably will play most of
the games but there's still people that
can step in what do you think of our
striking options
I mean obviously maimon is uh Harry
um phenomenal player
great goal scorer and once the score
goals and and is isn't contempt with
scoring one he wants three four five
what's that record yeah
I think
Harry can one of those players that you
couldn't you trust in those life and
death football situations as well we've
seen him before like if clean that cool
yeah
the only thing I will say is um he's
he's a captain so forwards they really
only want to focus on themselves yeah if
you only want to focus on that that when
you're a captain you've got to really
think of everything else so uh everyone
else and everything else so I think it
he's done really well on that side of it
because he's still getting the goals but
still managing to be that Captain and be
the player for for the for the squad so
I was lucky enough to play um in 2000
was it Tony Adams and then Shira and
then
um I played actually Gareth was the
captain at one stage as well so playing
with them players who they don't they
don't really think about themselves
think about everyone
and that's tough when you're off Striker
when you got really as you that I need
to score goals yeah so you were called
back into the squad at 2010 having
missed out previously what was that
Journey like
tough at times
um
obviously being called being left out
for four years I think it was and then
being called back
um
I think media wasn't too happy that I
was being called back but again if you
allow it you can eat you up but I didn't
allow it I just went and played and this
is where fans kind of
are great because they didn't feed into
what was being written they just read
into what you what how you play and I
played well so they they praised me for
that and yeah I just and then it it
spiraled into going to 2010. how did how
does it feel I guess you work so hard to
fight to get back in the England fold
and your scoring goals and you're
playing well and everyone's excited
about it to then have the media then say
ah why is he why is he backing us what's
going on here how does that make you fun
does it give you a little bit more of a
couple of hours to go let me show them
because it must be it must be annoying
yeah it's annoying but not not a a kick
up the backside to be honest with you
because
the fingers
if you're called back into something
it's why it's a reason that you can also
someone's seen something and they want
they want you to exploit that
but that someone doesn't have to be the
media that's not the the they're not
ones picking it so you can only do what
the manager wants you to do and that's
that's the key thing I always focus on
what the manager wants me to do I'm not
too worried about that you worry about
that when uh when you were like when I
was 18 19 20 whether I've got six in the
newspaper six doesn't really bother me
now yeah yeah yeah as long as what
manager wants me to do and that was the
key thing I just I was by that time I
was 30.
no it was actually uh Steve McLaren he
brought me up in 2008 but then I went
obviously cappella came a bit later and
that was capella was 2010 yes how did
you find working with capella
I actually enjoyed it because if I smile
on your face yeah
because because I'd come from a and I
was like 97 or something like 90 95 I
remember deep so um because I've come
through different areas of coaching
you'd see you've seen a lot of different
styles
didn't really bother me and he was he
was an aggressive he's an aggressive man
was he really yeah he was uh yeah yeah I
was talking to Karachi about a few bits
and he was like
yeah yeah well his face changed he was
yeah what was that because I mean I feel
like the tournaments that I've been
lucky enough to go to Just is doing
lines there and whatever it may be like
there's a lot of freedom you know
exactly allow players to be themselves
do what they want to do really to a
point
but that wasn't occasion no I don't
think no it wasn't uh again look you he
he had a certain way of doing things and
it was like that
um there was an incident to when we I
don't know where we flew
but we flew into somewhere and it was
just a long day and we what we usually
do is we put our bags down in our rooms
and then uh and we come back down for
dinner and then we have dinner together
and there's rules that you're not you're
not having your phone at dinner and blah
blah but this time we we literally
traveled so long we just said oh we're
not going to our rooms we're just gonna
put our bags down and go straight in and
I'm on my phone
in the dining room and he just and you
know the you know the the things that
you put they have the food and you know
the metal trays yeah yeah he just
flipped a couple of those over because
you were on your yeah but the
fascinating thing is so you know the
tables is just long tables on there yeah
because I'm sat there like that and
we're all sat there and we've all got
the phones on but he's he's spotted me
and then slowly yeah
just one meal in blah blah okay cool put
it away James like
what happened
what was the the kind of reaction
because I feel like that squad has some
characters in it how did they get along
because it's tough to be a character
with with an authoritarian manager I
didn't like it again and it come from an
era where we we basically you do as you
told him now really we're working with
the money you know yeah and you still do
as you told
and
um there was a certain section of
players like winning a lot of trophies
yeah so they're simple I'm winning it
doing this so why can't you adapt to the
way that we want to do it and and he
just wasn't willing to to adapt in that
way so did it create quite an unhappy
atmosphere in the camp
and I wouldn't say unhappy but there was
a there was a uh there was people who
weren't happy with like fragments you
take away ketchup yeah I'm not that
bothered about ketchup too much if you
take away ketchup I won't eat it I won't
have it but like they were section at
one time in your career you're scoring
goals for Liverpool you you're top of
the world and someone's gone you know
what's going to help your game no
ketchup you're not I don't think you're
probably as awesome it's not about
ketchup I don't care about ketchup but
if I want kids I couldn't have ketchup
surely like you don't need to be that
pedantic about what yeah I I get that
but again like I said I'd come from a
different era where the manager's like
yeah as you told kind of thing so if he
says I'm not gonna have ketchup I don't
have ketchup ketchup outside of the
hotel if you want me to do you know what
I mean so it it it became a bit of a
battle yeah yeah yeah
I'll not conducive to it to a happy
tournament back down but others probably
didn't want to back down yeah so you
know when we're talking about Capello
there and it was all very strict
how do you think Gareth Southgate is
doing that in fact Josh I think I just
realized I'm sort of sitting here with
two like an England International and a
half oh no yeah
yeah mate you're too International
Football you might as well just say you
got the call up
um a Happy Camp Galaxy that seems to be
one of his like Hallmark defining
features doesn't it I think that's a
good idea yeah 100 again when you're
together for that long as in a
tournament is tough
um so trying to keep everyone happy and
keep everyone inclusive
um I think that's a key thing I think
he's done fantastic in that I think he's
done in fantastic in connecting the fans
as well
um because that was one thing that we
never we never really had that
connection we never really had it
because again
our connection with the fans was
probably through the media but now he's
the now is the social media is directed
to the phones yeah yeah you're actually
doing we're doing
talk shows we're doing stuff with them
yeah regularly so you feel that you're
actually in the camp but we'll kind of
just there in the middle and no one else
allowed in them blah blah so I think
he's done a fantastic job in that and
and connecting with the fans because
even for myself who who's played for
England I feel like I'm now still part
of that if that makes sense yeah yeah I
know what you mean it's weird isn't it
he's managed to make even me feel like
yeah it's done incredibly well there
yeah is it all genuine Josh you know
when you're at St George's Park and I
don't know you're looking at Makai Osaka
mucking about on a unicorn and all that
yeah it is the atmosphere as genuinely
happy as it looks I I was so blessed to
be a part of that because genuinely it
was such a happy it was such a happy
environment it was such a chilled
environment like I remember walking in
and they've set up their the basketball
court in the middle there's a jukebox
over there there's ping pong tables
there's like a whole chill out area
where they go and watch love about it
like this it it the whole atmosphere was
was fantastic you know what it's like a
tournament where you spend three four
weeks anywhere and you're likely to kind
of get on each other's nerves honestly
there was absolutely none of that and
that's because calf went right it's a
different generation of players that we
need to we need to kind of look after
them we need to make sure that they are
as comfortable as possible and happy
they are the better they play and you
forget that this generation like it's
something like the kind of most random
people who knock about together because
they've played together from 15 16 17
18. they've been in all the squads
together so they've known each other for
10 years they're 25. yeah so it's like
I think this is probably the best
atmosphere I've ever seen within an
English word and I'm doing Lions then
and kind of having that connection with
the fans it's just even having that was
a nice way for the players to then
interact with the fans and they'd ask me
to go have you seen this is what clip
we've got today from the fan Zone all
right my mate in New York players are
Keen to find out what the clip is the
players are into the face yeah because
I've got like this like if you've got
I've got a friend in New York and he
sent me a video of one of the reactions
to one of the goals Harry's like oh my
unbelievable
and it's like it's it's nice to see and
even with like it's a different
generation so like there was a battle
between like Chile Saka and grealish on
the filters and there's like a long nose
filter and there's like a big foot
filter and all this stuff and you'll see
them they'll be walking around like
snipers
I was like oh man I'm getting I'm
getting killed on these filters so I
keep I'm descending stupid Facebook and
then next time he's got Jack and he's
like oh thanks for that bro but it's
like they're like kids you know I mean
it's like they're just they're just kids
but they happen to be playing in the
biggest tournaments I love that do you
think you see what Josh was saying
they're about like the Happy vibe from
the fans do you as a theory what do you
think to this do fans say in a stadium
have a genuine result on the result of
the football match they will do
um
we talk about being the 12th man it's
100 the energy that you give is the
energy that they receive some can some
some have a filter where they don't even
think about certain things but some
really feed off that
um I've seen I've seen players be sick
when they're before they're going onto a
pitch just thinking about going onto a
pitch
because I don't know what energies are
going to get from the fans I don't know
but then once you're on the picture Okay
um but yeah the energy that you give as
a fan
is what sometimes can be portrayed onto
a pitch right so fans have an actual
window oh yeah a little bit with the
Euros not necessarily in a home
tournament but by all means it was a
home tournament the energy that was
radiating out of Wembley yeah was was
frightening I think it got us through
games it helped us hold on in games yeah
and even speaking to some of the players
it's like the Scotland gamer talking
about atmosphere was it didn't expect
the atmosphere to be as crazy as it was
yeah it was like you know the comment
and it knocks you back it's like the
boys would get like Jesus Christ it was
a special show up for this well you know
after this chat I shove up for this
world cup Emil do you think we can
actually do it the thing is yeah 100 we
can't actually do it but again there's
got to be a couple of you need luck yeah
for sure we need luck and we're hoping
we're praying for that that little bit
of look that will take us there a little
bit of luck
um thank you so much it's an honor to
have you here we really really
appreciate your time
um Josh keep me fully in the loop of
everything going on out there honestly
I'm I'm absolutely buzzing so I think
this comes out when I'm already out
there sorry yeah I'll have a bit more of
a Time
unbelievable thank you so much to
everybody watching this episode of sport
Bible stories we really do appreciate it
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below and we'll see you all on
the next episode
[Music]
I would beat the person opposite me at a
round of golf
can you show your swing yeah
[Music]